russia and ukraine are taking heavy
casualties in the donbass but has
ukraine already lost the east
[Music]
my guest this week believes that is
likely the case
ian bremer is a political scientist and
founder of the eurasia group it is very
clear that the cost that russia is going
to pay
economically politically and
strategically for a generation or more
will be very severe and that and we
can't we can't forget about that and we
also discussed the impact of a conflict
that has had a broader effect on global
stability all this and more on this
week's conflict zone
[Music]
ian bremer welcome to conflict zone
happy journey now the battle for ukraine
is slowly dangerously close to becoming
a frozen conflict ukraine is facing 10
times the number of artillery guns it
has
according to some reports losing up to
200 soldiers a day and russia is making
small but incremental gains could
ukraine be on the verge of losing the
donbass
um it's certainly losing most of the
donbass
it's hard to imagine
that they would be able to retake
the territory that would bring them back
to the pre-february 24th lines of
conflict and i think that those are
minimum table stakes for an effective
negotiation
um so i mean what we're looking at
is a situation where the russians
are increasingly able to declare victory
in their more much more modest and scale
down
war aims from this so-called second
phase
of the special military operations the
uh
luhansk and donetsk as well as the land
bridge to crimea
but of course
um russia's position globally
is vastly worse uh they're losing uh the
war against europe the war against u.s
the war against nato let's just stay
with the situation in ukraine for a
moment i do want to discuss europe but
let's just talk about ukraine for a
second russia clearly has the numerical
advantage and as you mentioned it is
declaring these small wins in the
eastern regions what needs to happen to
tip the balance in ukraine's favor
well you know russia's defense spending
is 10 times
that of ukraine's on an annual basis now
the extraordinary amount of
international support
has narrowed that gap
this year
and there's no question that the morale
of the ukrainian troops
fighting for their homeland fighting for
their families fighting for their
existence
uh also provides advantages
to the ukrainians that the russians
cannot bring to the front
but
it's still david versus goliath
and now that the russians are focusing
uh almost all of their troops
on a much more uh compact area
it's it's honestly hard to imagine
that the ukrainians are going to be able
to stop them it's certainly true
that if the west were to provide heavier
weapons
faster
in the coming weeks that maybe they
could prevent the russians from taking
even more territory luhansk is basically
done donetsk maybe they can stop so why
isn't the west providing heavier weapons
the way ukraine has been pleading since
at least april why is the pace of
delivery so slow
um well in in the ca the united states
has been responsible for um the lion's
share of the defense support so far
and in some cases
it's because there's a reluctance to
provide
the heaviest weapons uh for fear of uh
escalating uh the war beyond ukraine's
borders that definitely and by the way
the europeans felt the same way no we're
not sending tanks then maybe we'll send
tanks we're not sending helicopters
maybe we'll send helicopters so i mean
there has been a shift in the
perspective of different nato countries
over the last four months uh some of it
honestly is that the americans don't
suddenly it's not like they have a whole
bunch of surplus weaponry that they've
just been sitting on and doing nothing
with
in some cases they are actually sending
what they have available and and there
needs to be increased production so i
think both of those things are going on
right now now the u.s has recently
announced a further one billion dollars
in uh military assistance for ukraine
the uk has announced a fast-track
training program for ukrainian troops
will this pick up the pace of heavy
weapons deliveries to ukraine
uh yeah but again i i don't think that
this is not going to fundamentally
change my view
that the russians are likely to be able
to take most if not all
of the donbass and also likely maintain
their control
of the land bridge
to crimea including uh the city of
hair-san
now ukrainian president zelinski has
warned that
it is facing that ukraine is facing
increased attacks from russia while the
european union considers whether to
admit ukraine into the eu family or not
so these heavy weapons that ukraine
wants aren't coming to ukraine and then
there is the reality as you mentioned
that russia is likely to take a control
of the donbass what is ukraine supposed
to do how is it supposed to withstand
this renewed russian onslaught
well
the extraordinary amount of support that
the west has provided for ukraine let's
be clear it's vastly greater than anyone
would have expected if you had said that
the russians are going to invade on
february 24th
and i don't think any external analysts
would have expected the billions and
billions of dollars that have been
provided
but i want to be clear
this is not only about ukraine
withstanding an attack
from a country that has commercial 10
times
its own military and defense forces
it's also about punishing the russians
and if the russians are going to
continue to engage in war crimes they're
going to continue to invade an innocent
country for no reason other than the
fact they want to choose their own
government
then the russians are going to be
permanently cut off
from the western economy and that those
level of sanctions are greater than
anything we've ever seen applied against
the g20 economy now that doesn't save
ukraine that doesn't save the millions
of ukrainian refugees that doesn't make
the donbass
suddenly ukrainian i accept that
but it is very clear that the cost that
russia is going to pay
economically politically and
strategically for a generation or more
will be very severe and that and we
can't we can't forget about that okay
let's look at punishing the russians you
talked about punishing the russians
let's look at the short term you were
talking about the long term here
president macron of france had earlier
said that russia should not be
humiliated and then he was in key with
other eu leaders and he talks about
ukraine winning saying ukraine must win
what do you think changed on the ground
for
that that made president macron say what
he said
what did what changed that
the massacres in bucha and european
could not force him to say that ukraine
must win look i i think that uh this
whole russia must not be humiliated it's
an exciting
um
statement
that makes great headlines
and is differentiated from biden and
that's why we talk about it a lot
but
you know france has been sending weapons
to ukraine and france has been a leader
in six rounds of unprecedented european
sanctions
against russia
uh for the reality of france's position
uh on russia and ukraine is virtually
identical to germany's it's virtually
identical to that of the biden
administration now look i am
i also would i believe that putin
shouldn't be humiliated uh the only
problem is that the person that's doing
most of the humiliating of putin is
putin
and you know there's a very easy way for
putin to stop being humiliated and that
is to pull his troops
out of ukraine
and back to the borders that had been at
least at the very least at an absolute
minimum
where the russians were on february 23rd
which frankly i mean even that is
unacceptable given that they're still
occupying ukrainian territory but that
would be the fastest way for putin to
end his humiliation i think the macron
understands that so is that what ukraine
winning looks like so when macron says
ukraine must win is that what he means
i don't think it will feel like a win
to the ukrainian people
i think that when you have hundreds of
thousands of ukrainians that are
infiltration camps in russia abducted
and taken away from their country
against their will when you have tens of
thousands of ukrainian civilians that
have been killed in cold blood
um in inside ukraine
when you have pieces of their territory
including the formerly occupied
informally occupied territory of the
donbass and crimea that russia still
sits on
you've got millions of refugees in the
homes of europeans outside of ukraine
this is a level of personal tragedy that
every single ukrainian will feel
and frankly i think it will be uh
the most important
um historic
part of their lives
for generations
and so i don't know how you can live
through that i don't know how you can
live through the short term
win for ukraine is that what you're
saying
i'm saying that i don't believe look my
i i come from partially in armenian
family and i don't think anyone that's
been through the armenian genocide can
say that they won during that period and
i i think from the ukrainians that i've
met both in and out of the government
over the last few months these are
traumatized people personally deeply
traumatized people i don't think that
it's appropriate to speak of ukraine
winning after experiencing that now the
institute for the study of war in a june
11 assessment was quoting ukrainian
intelligence and it said that russia is
planning to prolong the war till at
least october this year if not longer
uh
i'm wondering what what that does for
the one thing that you said ukraine has
going for it it's morale
uh i i think that uh again the
ukrainians are fighting for survival and
i think as we saw from people that lived
through the nazi era
that uh you know that fighting for
survival
means fighting as long as it takes
so i think that you'll find that
ukrainian morale on the ground the
troops will continue to be shockingly
high but i i just don't think they'll
have the resources
uh to continue to fight the way they
have against the russians over the first
three months of this conflict when they
push the russians out of the surrounding
areas of kiev out of the surrounding
areas of har kiev which is the second
largest city in ukraine
i just think i mean this is a
david versus goliath story and and you
can't can you can't expect realistically
expect that ukrainians can keep that up
for years let's be clear what about
europe boris johnson is warning of
ukraine fatigue can europe match putin's
resolve if this war stretches out
uh no they can't match putin's resolve
in ukraine but they can absolutely
overmatch putin's resolve
for everything else uh i mean let's keep
in mind that the longer this war goes on
the more the russians are going to be
advantaged in ukraine but the more they
will be disadvantaged in terms of their
leverage
over europe i mean once the europeans no
longer need russian coal they're not
going back russian oil they're not going
back russian gas they're not going back
the longer
the time of this war goes on
um the less reliance the europeans have
on the russian economy but
in then and india for instance
yes that's right um there are customers
in china and india um the indians are
buying more oil they're not buying more
russian weapons because you don't want
to buy helicopters when they don't have
spare parts and of course a big part of
russia's economy was they were the
second largest military exporter in the
world that will go away because they
will not no longer have that capacity
the europeans are talking about
boycotting your uh shipping services
insurance and reinsurance that's 90 of
all shipping of oil that comes out of
russia irrespective of where it goes
whether europe or other places
and of course even with the indians the
chinese buying more oil at high prices
the imf expectation of
russian gdp contraction this year is
over 10 percent
and i have some sources inside uh moscow
that believe that it's closer to 15
percent um that's pretty severe i think
anyone would argue that's that's a
that's a greece-style depression that
the west is enforcing that europe is
enforcing against russia but none of
that is of any consolation to the
ukrainians who are looking at losing the
donbass and potentially the south of
ukraine
not just that none of that's any
consolation to the ukrainians who have
had six million refugees who have had
war crimes committed against them and
the russians that have committed those
war crimes that are back in russia
are have impunity so again i would argue
with you that there is no that you're
not going to provide satisfaction
um to a country of 44 million people
that has been unjustly invaded now
lithuanian president getanas no cedar
said in march i'd like to quote him
putin will not stop in ukraine if he
will not be stopped and now we have
russia demanding lithuania stop
enforcing eu sanctions that prohibit the
transit of russian goods into the
enclave of kaliningrad and grad yeah
could this escalate is something going
to happen in kaliningrad or
lithuania well the russians have said it
will escalate
but uh let's keep in mind that lithuania
like all the baltics are nato states and
if they're invaded that would lead to a
nato response i don't think that the
russians given the challenges they're
having on the ground in ukraine are
particularly eager for a second front in
that war so i expect that russia's
escalation will be largely symbolic i
think there have been some some signs of
that in the last
24 hours um look the lithuanians are
plenty angry at russia
and like most of europe
they are fully on board
with the very with the unprecedented
tough sanctions that are being leveled
but should the baltic nations and other
eastern european countries be preparing
for war
um
you know it it is a wartime
and by the way i should make the
argument that if the europeans are about
to uh provide
candidate member status
to ukraine
then that will mean that the european
union will be directly at war with
russia right i mean that's kind of what
they're saying
so i mean i i i think that the europeans
are preparing for war um it's a cold war
right now uh but there are elements of
hot war espionage cyber attacks
disinformation it's a very dangerous
time this is existential for you we've
seen eastern european countries
particularly and the baltic nations
generally on one side of nato generally
on the same page when it comes to
supporting ukraine and on the other
extreme you have
western nations western european nations
like france and germany how do you view
france and germany are they essentially
in the business of appeasing russia at
the moment
i i think that's an incredible misread
um anyone that would say that i'm not
suggesting you're saying that i know
you're just asking the question
um i mean yes there are differences
nuance differences between poland
wanting to provide more heavy weapons
for example and france and germany a
little bit more reluctant but the
overwhelming message
that the europeans and the americans and
the canadians have delivered in the last
months has been support for ukraine it's
been direct defense support it's been
humanitarian support and it's been six
rounds of sanctions and the europeans of
course are taking it on the chin uh i
mean the hungarians aren't completely on
board and serbia which is not a member
of the eu is not on board but
overwhelmingly the europeans have been
sticking together here and the idea
anyone that would argue that the french
and the germans are trying to appease
the russians
either their their their russian
propagandists and not admitting it to
you um or they're being dishonest jens
stoltenberg has said that the war will
most likely end at the negotiating table
and what happens there will be
determined effectively by the situation
on the battlefield so you do believe
that germany and france are doing
everything they can to make sure that
ukraine has a strong negotiating
position at those stocks even when they
happen
no of course i don't believe that
neither are the americans neither the
polls i mean there's no no-fly zone i
saw the polish government was willing to
provide aircraft for a no-fly zone as
long as they didn't have to send it
directly so the polish government isn't
doing everything they can
i don't see the polls sending troops um
to fight side by side with ukraine even
though the polish government has told me
that they consider the ukrainians
fighting for poland fighting so that the
polls don't have to um so no no one
would argue that they're doing
everything they can
but they're certainly doing much more
than anyone would have expected and
they're working together which i think
is very important now the italians
presented a ceasefire plan in may and
point three of that four-point plan
essentially put the donbass the state of
the donbass and uh crimea up for
discussion with russia
do you get the impression that western
europe is happy to sacrifice donbass in
crimea if it puts a stop to the war
uh no
uh i get the sense that western europe
believes that the ukrainian government
are the principal negotiators they've
been the ones fighting they've been the
ones dying they've been the ones
suffering and it was very clear when the
french president the italian prime
minister the german chancellor and the
romanian president for fun
um all showed up in kiev last week and
they all made it very clear that any
negotiation that will ever occur with
putin will be led by the ukrainians and
that is of course the appropriate
position now you had said in an
interview to dw to a colleague of mine
at the munich security conference that
russia wants to find ways to divide nato
what you're saying is russia has failed
that's right
russia has actually putin has succeeded
in uniting and strengthening nato's
nato in ways that american presidents
had only dreamed of i mean trump failed
biden failed obama failed they couldn't
get the germans to spend two percent on
defense they couldn't get the french and
swedes to say the finns and swedes to
say they wanted to join they couldn't do
permanent deployments forward
deployments um they couldn't get the
europeans to recognize that their peace
dividend did not mean that they could
ignore national security putin has
accomplished all of those things and
more for nato so absolutely putin has
putin has succeeded in strengthening
nato i don't think that was his
intention but he has succeeded speaking
of u.s presidents under uh president
donald trump he initially withheld 400
million dollars in in the military aid
package to ukraine over a quid pro court
to do with hunter biden joe biden son
and this was in the middle of a conflict
that was raging in ukraine's east
did an action like this enable putin and
his ambitions in ukraine
no not really um though i i you remember
it is true that trump was impeached the
second time for that action um and uh of
course he wasn't convicted because
impeachment is broken as a political
process in the united states but it
speaks volumes that he was impeached for
that um the fact is that putin decided
to invade for a number of reasons uh
when putin met with biden a year ago in
switzerland it was largely biden's
agenda biden was talking mostly about
cyber attacks because the colonial
pipeline hit he did not put ukraine high
on the agenda putin surely noticed that
he thought biden was comparatively weak
especially after the afghanistan
withdrawal thought the united states was
focusing more on china as they were saw
that merkel was out merkel was the one
that of course was much more hard-line
in terms of ukraine specifically and
much more focused on the donbass and on
the minsk accords accordingly saw that
macron was going in his own direction
saw that xi jinping
was his best friend on the global stage
and of course also saw uh that russia
had much more energy and gas influence
over europe as winter was coming just
like to talk about the united states
over here it was trump who initially
pulled away funding from ukraine but
then released it and then you had in may
just this may 11 republicans in the
senate and i think it was 57 in the
house who voted against the 40 billion
package of funding for ukraine if trump
was withholding money there seems to be
a mood to do that now as well isn't
there
a mood well i mean given that this is
one of the most bipartisan packages that
had gotten support in the united states
i mean the americans agree on nothing
right now democrats and republicans the
amount of support um you know
overwhelming majorities in the house and
senate for 40 billion dollars for
ukraine a country most of them hadn't
heard of
before february 24th is a staggering
amount of support i mean you know it is
true that you can find a few people that
weren't in favor of it but actually the
biden administration only wanted 33
billion and republicans
republicans demanded more how long will
the support hold i just wanted to quote
a poll by npr pbs they said that
president biden's ratings are down over
his handling of ukraine and the number
one concern amongst most americans is
inflation prices are going up and most
of them believe that republicans can do
a better job of reigning in inflation
than the democrats my indication is what
does this mean for the midterm polls
that are coming up
oh no look biden's going to get
destroyed in the midterms and the
democrats will lose the house but
i i have i am incredulous that you found
a poll that said that biden's numbers
are going down because of ukraine
americans do not know hardly anything
about ukraine they don't vote on the
basis of ukraine um they're going down
because of inflation so how much how
much will ukraine be a priority november
onwards in the united states
oh i mean the united states is already
losing interest in ukraine that's pretty
clear uh it's hard for me to imagine
that you're going to get the same kind
of support for ukraine next year as you
got this year but i promise you that
you'll get the same kind of punishment
of russia that you got this year so once
again i mean it's going to be harder for
ukraine in 2023 but russia is going to
take it in the teeth and putin's not
going to look like a winner here he's
going to look like he's been absolutely
destroyed by the west but that works for
putin doesn't it because he gets to
consolidate his positions in ukraine and
for him that counts as a win and there
is no guarantee he does not threaten any
other european country
i i don't i i have it look if i were
advising putin and look please don't
wish that upon me
um clearly i would tell him to try to
announce his uh ukraine territory as a
win
but his economy is uh being contracted
um his uh he he can't his his athletes
can't compete under the russian flag um
his oligarchs are having their assets
frozen half of his central bank assets
have been unprecedentedly frozen uh nato
is expanding uh the finnish border is a
unprecedented expansion uh i mean you
know if he said this was all about nato
before he invaded ukraine and as i said
and as you you certainly understand um
nato has gotten a lot stronger i mean no
matter putin can paint this however he
wants this is an unmitigated disaster
for putin
ian bremmer that's about all we have
time for
we leave it there for the timing thank
you so much for being on conflict zone
sure good to see you
[Music]
you